hey guys it is Friday and I've swapped
out this earlier week said for another
ed say hi Eddie this is the longest my
hair's been in 28 years not relevant to
the show about a nice to do it for you
for what is relevant to the show what
we're going to do is I take some of the
stories from this week and drill down
into them and have a chat about them and
I'll let us know what you think in the
comment section but let's get started
[Music]
so Paris games week happened this week
which means we've got a bunch of
trailers - got a bunch of new bits and
pieces that we found out about
announcements and one of the biggest
trailers that landed was a brand new one
for the Last of Us - which was really
hard to watch first thing in the morning
yeah so the first thing I saw when I
woke up that morning was that trailer
and yeah that might not have been the
first thing I wanted to see in the
morning do you want to describe
basically what it was so there's a you
know the characters are coming into a
camp being dragged kicking and screaming
yes in the background you see of
different characters who are being
hanged so that's the setup is like
disemboweling and attempted
disemboweling and ultimately one of the
girls gets her arms hammered in like at
the elbow and I think we're all sitting
there being as used to trails as we are
being like they'll cut away they don't
and a lot of people came back there was
some backlash being like is this your
violent is this just like getting to the
level of sensationalist violent like to
kind of promote Last of Us and what
PlayStation did is they came back with
an official response to all of that
backlash so Jim Ryan has basically said
that the Last of Us obviously is a game
made by adults to be played by adults
I should never prejudge this but it will
probably be rated 18 I think it's fair
to say and there's that market for those
people who like that sort of game so
he's basically saying that you know
they're they're kind of putting the
responsibility on the players that
they're getting into this experience
knowing what's gonna happen right and I
think that's another huge component of
is the context so we didn't have a lot
of context for this specific scene and I
know a game director Neil druckmann who
said you know context is very important
and they are specifically leaving out
that context yeah
because obviously you know severe story
focus gaming they don't want to give too
much away too early so while that scene
was very you know gripping and
disturbing we don't really know the
whole story yet it's all about you know
if the story backs up the violence then
it's kind of like a Tarantino movie
though it's not just violence for
violence sickness yeah and I guess the
other thing was you know it's about
Ellie and that scene didn't feature
Ellie sir people are wondering how is
that relevant you just showing it for
the sake of showing it and Ryan replied
to that by saying I think what we're
trying to do is portray qualities in the
various games we had on the show and I
think it's difficult when you have a
clip of four to five minutes to
synthesize the gameplay experience that
can be measured in the tens of hours but
then obviously he says he doesn't want
to speak for nobody dog and their
intentions of showing that specific clip
but when he was asked if he thought it
was the right thing for them to show at
the media showcase he was pretty adamant
that it was it's an adult game I mean
it's not a game that probably kids that
were going to play or should play so
there are going to be the scene but if
you played the first game obviously you
know that this is the world of the last
of us it's harsh and foreboding yeah and
uh let us know where you stand on this
one in that coin box said we'll be down
for John so one of the best games of
this year that some people missed out on
because it came out almost exactly the
same time Zelda did is a horizon which
is getting more gameplay DLC yeah of the
new expansion frozen wilds is out next
week so very very soon and and this week
we learned a little bit more about
what's gonna be in there principally
that it's gonna be 15 hours of
additional content pretty amazing I I
think I clocked it at almost 50 hours
around 50 hours so to get like another
15 hour chunk it's gonna be massive and
obviously as you'd expect that's like 50
15 hours of story content of side-quests
content there's more beasties it's it's
quite extensive there's also like an
extra skill tree like it's a bunch of
other stuff you can put in there which
isn't something I think you normally
expect to see for the deal city of an
action-adventure so that's pretty cool
with the expansion 2 or with the base
game you know it's obviously about
mystery and the story and figuring it
like annoy figuring things out and that
connect that is that trend continues
with frozen wilds
you don't exactly or sony has not said
exactly where this is said based on the
teaser images and trailers we've seen it
looks like Yellowstone in America so
that's exciting just to explore that
part of the world I think that'll be fun
to see yeah along with that skill tree
comes a bunch of new abilities um stuff
that's really handy like you can now
fart while mountain because anyone who's
played horizon there's a getting off
your mount version getting Oddy games
coming uh and also for the uh oddest
among you of the federal urge just
getting revamp to go any further imagine
how be cool I've never been that great
at those things but I appreciate looking
at other people's photos the composition
and then this seems like another great
you know last week at PAX we spoke with
Tim Stobo a divot developer on horizon
and the new expansion he talked about
you know the future of single-player
games and it's also spoke with us about
you know everything that players can
expect from this new expansion so you
can go check that out again so finally
we've got some intel on how long cool GT
world watches campaign is going to be
and for those of you hoping it would be
significantly longer than usual it's not
it's gonna be bouncing our viewer Miguel
concepción has clocked it at almost six
and a half hours so that's if you play
call you day that is what to expect from
call the UT game which is not saying
anything good or bad about the game it's
just you know that's how long it might
take to play and obviously that number
depends on your play style how much time
you want to take it's also worth noting
that we played on normal so you might
find it to be easier and go quicker at
you know easy and then obviously it
could take you much much longer at the
most expert difficulty think about that
like do you think people were hoping for
it to be longer or do you think people
not really don't mind I think that you
know this is just that's Call of Duty's
formula like they want to get you into
the multiplayer so six hours I mean
that's what it's been for the past
decade and obviously you know six hours
might sound short but there's you know
there's zombies mode there's actually
multiplayer so you could be potentially
playing hundreds and hundreds of hours
in this game as we expect people to yeah
: ad World War two is out today on Xbox
ps4 and PC so and our review will be up
right now that is everything
yes today do let us know what you
thought of today's discussion point
stories um as I said before we'll be
around over the next few days to have a
chat with you about them in that comment
section if that's something you want to
do but otherwise have yourselves a great
weekend and we'll see you again next
week yeah so let us know what you think
and that's the end of this segment
press X to join the fight press X to
join the fight
[Music]